drew smiley as bj said a moment ago
unbeaten in his last 11 starts and with
a left hand around the mount a couple of
primary offensive players nick green are
out of the starting nine for david bell
tonight yeah you know drew smiley's got
to take advantage of that his last three
starts haven't been real good his last
start went four innings against saint
louis 75 pitches a few too many pitches
the first inning really hurt him but i
thought things got better as the game
went on and hopefully today he builds up
those last three innings from his last
start slow slower slowest is down on
strikes two up two down for drew smiley
wow drew set him up really good with a
fastball up in his own and we see strike
three right there
castillanos didn't think much of that
call back-to-back strikeouts for drew
smiley he retires the reds in order and
the braves are coming up no score
tonight though guys they run into a
veteran sonny gray the pride of
vanderbilt
he's looking for his fifth victory of
the year nick yeah those numbers are a
little bit deceiving as bj said his last
four starts have not been good 19 ings
25 hits still has that strikeout stuff
but runners score vision have been a
problem for him he's a sinker guy four
seam curve ball and slider has four plus
pitches
broken bat little pop into shallow left
aquino coming on won't get there solaire
big and strong has a broken bad hit
and the braves have a threat here in the
bottom of the first inning this is why
he's so good because he's so big and
strong
right into stevenson's glove
sonny gray's first k and he works around
the solaire leader
scoreless
motto
to right field
over solar's head kicks off the wall bad
route to it bono easily jogs up to
second
with a double now he's at second for our
steedies aquino aristides aquino booms
with a deep left center field gone
the punisher pops a two-run homer
and the reds have the lead
two to nothing duvall a chance to tie it
up
with a home run swing and a high fly
ball deep left field did he get enough
aquino to the wall we are tied 2-2
this is so adam duvall
with a man on base he is just a
different hitter
in the air toward right center field can
anybody catch up
john peterson
off the bat i thought that was headed
for the gap without problem but it hung
up for peterson who made a tumbling
catch for out number one
and i don't know whether he thought it
was more than right field
but great effort here
shallow center akiyama coming on slides
and makes the catch
akiyama
has had some very strong glove work for
the reds in center field of them
and he'll lead off the atlanta sixth
against tambourine he greets him with a
first pitch single
one thing for sure will jettison a
club's hopes for making postseason play
and that is an offense
that feels like it has to win the game
two or three times a night great hitters
count three balls in a strike
and nowhere near
rays have gotten two walks from the reds
in the inning
the bases are loaded
and stephen vogt is coming up
24 000 plus roaring with a 3-2 pitch
he missed the braves lead on a bases
loaded free pass
three walks in the inning
that's a terrific at-bat right there by
stephen bolt getting behind o2
yet being patient
he did and slowly rolls it out toward
vato who's got it sesa throws one pitch
and gets the reds out of a giant mess
the reds walk three give up a hit but
atlanta takes the lead 3-2 as we head to
the seven
he has that zone
whistled inside the bag fair that's
going to be an extra base hit
saler around first
aquino rips it back to the infield and
the braves in business solaire has his
second hit
he's been on base three more times
tonight
up the middle india
makes the throw
and sesa keeps it a one-run game
rodriguez pitched in just three games
covering two and a third innings with
pittsburgh
line to short snap throw back to first
they got it
wandered too far off the bag
it's a double play
for the moment that will end the inning
almost certainly you figure the reds
will take a look
and the rule of course is there has to
be clear and convincing evidence greg
gibson's the man at first that made the
call
verdict is in and the batter runner is
safe jerry davis the crew chief made the
call
so the reds challenge
and do so
successfully
[Music]
castillano's left field splashes down in
front of duvall
naked went up to second base
tying run in scoring position
mancigretti is 1-2
struck him out they've got him twice
with that high fast ball
no argument from
just a shake of his head and metzic
comes in and puts out a cincinnati rally
in the eighth inning
wow the reach by voting the braves got
the call thank you very much 3-2 atlanta
it's 3-2 atlanta we go to the top of the
ninth inning will smith is on for the
braves he will face the five six and
seven hitters
for the cincinnati reds wills had a very
solid year 22 out of 25 in saves rough
outing last time out so you know fellas
he's happy to get back on the beam
tonight in game one
farmer opposite way goes gapping
down and all the way to the wall farmer
up to second base the tying run is in
scoring position as farmer in a
homecoming doubles in the night
left right at third base with suarez and
abustakas another pail
up and away it's suarez walks
this is about as animated as we have
seen eugenio suarez in a long time
both of those have come after bases on
balls
the o2 pitch
on the ground freddie's got it there's
one the throw to first is in time it's a
double play
and the braves have won game one
excellent play by freddie freeman
throwing to the outside making sure to
hit suarez in the back easy double play
to end this ball game just what the
doctor ordered nick